but what's the story behind the story
how can it make sense for airlines to
provide a service for just one passenger
who just paid 46 pounds for her ticket
let's ask the independence travel
editors Simon Calder who is also in
Greece obviously the place to be making
the most of these empty aeroplanes
what's going on here how can this
possibly be viable well exactly and
there's probably an awful lot of
shareholders at airlines thinking hang
on I thought airlines were supposed to
be filling their planes 95 percent fall
not 0.5 percent full but actually
there's a very good explanation for this
and normally at this time of year it is
a really odd time for the airlines
that's because this coming Saturday the
summer schedules for airlines right
around the world come to an end and the
pattern certainly to here in Greece of
flying is very very different instead of
having dozens of flights a day you
really just get a handful and so Karen
grieve from who spent 46 pounds the only
passenger on that flight will not be
able to fly back to Glasgow I've checked
and it's going to take at least three
hops to get back there so you've got
very low demand because basically you're
there what a beautiful place to be but
you've got the problem of coming back we
don't normally see it quite as Extreme
as that but this week if you want for
example to have most of a plane to
yourself well choose any of the flights
that are going off to briefs from some
of the regional airports like Leeds
Bradford to Hanyu this coming Saturday
you'll be paying 42 pounds for the seat
and I would imagine you'll probably get
an entire row to yourself if not an
entire ten rows or so Wow
so if someone wants to do this next
year's annual occurrence is that they'd
pop it in the diary did you experience
this on your flight over not quite as
good as that I did get three seats all
together but of course the airlines know
that that this is effectively an empty
Lake to use the industry jargon they are
making a mint and so Karen Greece flight
coming back from from directly on to
Glasgow was absolutely packed they would
have lost about 15,000 pounds on the way
out since she paid less than fifty quid
for hearse
they would have made probably I estimate
around 50,000 pounds which makes the
whole whole enterprise well worth doing
and the same thing applies for my fight
back this coming weekend it's going to
be completely round and the airline will
do very well out of it so sorry to
interrupt you Simon anyone concluding
from these pictures then that there's a
crisis in the aviation industry and see
what's happened to monarch and all the
problems with Ryanair they're actually
barking up the wrong tree
well there is a huge oversupply of seats
which has been slightly improved because
of the very sad failure of monarch and
that's going to mean some real bargains
during the winter but they're not gonna
be bargains where you get the entire row
of seats or indeed in the entire
aircraft to yourself a good way to go
about it is think ahead to next spring
and fly on the first inbound leg from
say Heraklion to Glasgow in early May
you'll probably have to pray to yourself
and you'll certainly pay a heck of a lot
less than the people who are flying out
from Glasgow on that very plainly
fantastic Simon called her from the
independent thanks so much